Phil Hartman may be one of the top five
performers on Saturday Night Live of all
time he was nine years older than me and
I idolized him he was the king of the
Groundlings he was the only one in the
group that had a job and he had his own
car new car and he had a house and the
rest of us were dead broke you know
right and uh he was like my big brother
and so I was always trying to get him on
Saturday Night Live and you know when he
he got the job and he turned it down
Saturday Night Live yeah and then I said
come on Phil and because I remember I
mentioned him to Lauren for the next
year and he goes well John how long has
he been in the Groundlings I said 10
years he goes and he hasn't made it yet
there must be a reason I go I I guess I
you know because I say Lauren listen if
you think I'm good you'll love Phil he's
a genius I mean and so I thought well
why hasn't he and he didn't really want
it you know I thought he didn't believe
in himself so when he he said no to the
show and then he said okay yes
so I called him up wanting the credit so
Phil did you change your mind because of
me because I convinced you
he's like no
I'm like why but wait a second this is
really Joel Silver the producer
convinced him I mean the guy was a
utility player he could play any
character he was just a brilliant
brilliant team oh yeah he and Jim Carrey
the only two guys I know that could
change their face and look like the
character they were playing without
makeup like how do you do that why would
a guy like that turn down Saturday Night
Live do you think it's like no I can
tell you why I'd go to his house and
he'd be on the phone when I got silent
live and I'd go to his house he had a
little house in the valley you know and
he loved it and he goes hey my guess
who's here my friend John Lovitz the
star of Saturday Night Live and I'm like
hey I don't know so he but he'd say that
and and then go Phil you should get on
the show no no I like my life I'm happy
and you know I because he was writing
scripts like he wrote Peewee Herman's
Big Adventure he co-wrote it like 125
Grand he goes for a script he goes
that's enough money I like my life I
don't want to be famous I don't want any
of that crazy but I think deep down he
did want it you know but it he'd been
there for 10 years and you know how he
got in the Groundlings he went there for
a birthday party to see a show
and then there was an intermission and
all the actors were backstage and and
they and they hear the audience like
dying laughing and they go what's going
on and they went out there and Phil was
on stage entertaining everybody and they
were kidding this guy's great they go
you want to be in the group he'd never
done it he could just do it what was
Phil doing before he joined the
Groundlings was he a comedy he was a
graphic designer and his brother
um John Hartman was a manager of groups
like uh Poco and America and Crosby
Stills and Nash and he said to Phil I
need a best of America can you do an
album cover so Phil goes all right I'll
try then of course he his brother told
me he drew this thing goes you mean
something like this and his brother goes
something like this this you know why I
just could do it I he he could do
anything I mean plus he was the nicest
guy in the humblest guy you know it's
amazing to me a guy that talented and
confident goes to see the Groundlings
and somehow has the balls to walk up on
stage during an intermission when he's
never really performed and started
entertaining people I mean I wish I
could see what he did I mean that's
insane me too yeah everybody loved him
you know he was the only guy I know that
in every group he was in everyone loved
him from the Groundlings to Saturday
Night Live to news radio you know and
comedians they are they're very very
competitive you know and zombie always
has a problem with somebody but not Phil